es un viaje a través del tiempo durante
un fin de semana este festival reúne a
miles de personas nostálgicas de un
pasado idealizado
la entrada gratuita para quienes usen
las tradicionales prendas este estilo se
llama campo literalmente la vestimenta
de la etnia mayoritaria de china los
hanes las tradiciones imperiales
suprimida durante la revolución cultural
ahora despiertan el interés en una
generación deseosa de reencontrarse con
esta herencia en un cuello alto la parte
delantera es abombada con mangas anchas
y esta falda es típica de la dinastía
ming
a sus 24 años li jing chen posee un
centenar de túnicas como ésta para ella
es mucho más que una moda
creo que es importante para las nuevas
generaciones con el ascenso de china y
el aumento del nivel de vida los chinos
le van a prestar más atención a esta
tradición creo que la cultura china
atrae cada vez a más personas
un orgullo nacional que se ha convertido
en un mercado lucrativo este año se
espera que las ventas totales de shampoo
alcancen más de 1000 millones de dólares
los aficionados pueden encontrar algo
para cada presupuesto incluyendo lo más
alto de la gama esta casa de moda ofrece
piezas únicas como este vestido de novia
cinco años de trabajo manual por 31 mil
dólares es un abrigo floral tiene que
estar cubierto de phoenix mariposas
pájaros y flores las reglas son muy
estrictas vienen de nuestros antepasados
lianhai jean la diseñadora lanzó esta
gama más asequible a unos 230 dólares
cada pieza en un año las ventas se han
duplicado según ella eso es una señal
del fuerte regreso del saber hacer chino
para pies
para mí es como alguien que lleva mucho
tiempo en el desierto y que tiene sed si
hay una sed cultural en china la
confianza de los chinos en su propia
cultura está regresando
la cueva más allá del campo el éxito del
made in chain incide en todos los bienes
de consumo cotidiano ropa electrónica o
cosméticos hace unos años la etiqueta
made in chain han desalentado a los
consumidores chinos amantes de las
marcas occidentales de lujo hoy en día
incluso la juventud de moda de shanghai
está empezando a consumir más localmente
antes pensábamos que las marcas
extranjeras eran las mejores pero ahora
las marcas chinas son cada vez mejores
estas prendas son chinas serás
comprendido a un diseñador chino de
streetwear
antes no compraba marcas nacionales me
pasa a las zapatillas chinas cuando
knife fue boicoteada por algunos
problemas
el problema es que tras una declaración
contra las acusaciones de trabajos
forzados de los uigures de la provincia
de xinjiang la famosa marca
estadounidense fue boicoteada en chino y
no fue la única tras unas declaraciones
similares y tienen desaparecido de los
sitios de compras en línea un boicot
aprobado por beijing
los internautas chinos son libres de
expresar lo que piensan tienen el honor
y la dignidad de su país en la más alta
estima
esto no es nacionalismo sino simplemente
patriotismo sin duda
comprar se vuelve un acto político y las
marcas patrióticas se hacen populares
tras las mortíferas inundaciones de este
verano en el centro del país esta marca
deportiva donó casi 8 millones de
dólares a las víctimas en pocos días la
empresa pasó de ser prácticamente
desconocida a tener tiendas en todo el
país en china la mayoría de las ventas
se realizan por internet
[Música]
a través de super influencers es la
estrella de estos grandes con claves
comerciales es ley y aquí en estos
vídeos en directo el joven millonario
recomienda todo tipo de productos a
decenas de millones de seguidores su
récord es de 1.700 millones de dólares
vendidos en sólo 12 horas muy lindo
color uno de los productos que más se
venden son los cosméticos sector
dominado en gran medida por los grandes
nombres de lujo europeo y he aquí
patrocina cada vez más marcas made in
china en la nueva fórmula hay flor de
loto
gracias a él la demanda se dispara
cuatro años después de su lanzamiento
esta empresa emergente de maquillaje ya
se ha convertido en un éxito en ventas
en internet actualmente emplea a unas
1.200 personas
no habíamos puesto ese detalle en la
primera versión y johann es uno de los
fundadores se ocupa del diseño
el ideó la firma de la marca
sofisticados objetos inspirados en el
pasado
esta porcelana es emblemática de la
artesanía tradicional china también la
elegimos porque la porcelana es una
estable muy difícil de trabajar que
tanto queríamos encontrar la manera de
adaptar la técnica a nuestra producción
en masa la estrategia funciona la
facturación del año pasado fue de más de
550 millones de dólares
creo que es la mezcla del lado joven y
popular mezclado con la cultura
tradicional lo que hace que la
generación movimos y lío
las marcas chinas pueden contar con este
deseo de consumo patriótico el 11 de
noviembre día de las rebajas monstruosas
en china la demanda de productos made in
china se duplicó en comparación con el
año pasado